Okay.
♫ Strolling along in Central Park ♫
♫ Everyone's out today ♫
♫ The daisies and dogwoods are all in bloom ♫
♫ Oh, what a glorious day ♫
♫ For picnics and Frisbees and roller skaters, ♫
♫ Friends and lovers and lonely sunbathers ♫
♫ Everyone's out in merry Manhattan in January ♫
(Laughter) (Applause)
♫ I brought the iced tea; ♫
♫ Did you bring the bug spray? ♫
♫ The flies are the size of your head ♫
♫ Next to the palm tree, ♫
♫ Did you see the 'gators ♫
♫ Looking happy and well fed? ♫
♫ Everyone's out in merry Manhattan in January ♫
(Whistling)
Everyone!
(Whistling) (Laughter)
♫ My preacher said, ♫
♫ Don't you worry ♫
♫ The scientists have it all wrong ♫
♫ And so, who cares it's winter here? ♫
♫ And I have my halter-top on ♫
♫ I have my halter-top on ♫
♫ Everyone's out in merry Manhattan in January. ♫
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Jill Sobule!